Congratulations! Congratulations! This is your last week of six-week
Renew and I'm very proud of each and every one of you and I've been so
pleased with the improvements and the enthusiasm of each and every student and
it's just been a fun fun ride. So today in mental fitness we're going to talk
about celebrations, no big deal, and so I want you to think of what celebrations
means to you and if you need to use a different word like like excitement or
bragging those are great words too but celebrations or just the idea around
celebrating is a really really important tool. We actually learned a few weeks ago
in our mounted exercise how much how important it is to communicate to the
horses when they're right. It's the same. It's the same importance. We need to
communicate to ourselves when we've accomplished something, when
we've achieved something, when we've amounted in a certain way over a certain
subject that we're working towards. So get your notebooks out because this is
pretty interactive. So we want to talk about celebrations meaning everything
from big to small. It's something that you have accomplished and it could be a
portion. So say you're trying to drink more water in a day and you drink
this much water that's still a celebration and when you drink all the
water it's still a celebration and when you drink the entire amount that you're
going for in a day then that is a huge celebration okay. So it's really it's
really vital that you do this. You're gonna start doing it very on purpose and
that's a habit that we're going to kind of break down today okay. So the smallest
you know celebration might be getting up in the morning. A bigger one might be
making your bed. A bigger one would be the way that you responded to a
conversation with your horse, with barn staff, with some people around you, with
your family, whatever aspect of your life this goes across your whole life. It can
be used in any subject not just writing but this is what we're going to talk
about okay. Now the one thing I want to bring to your attention is that these
small things compound very heavily in your life. If you work out once how much
accomplishment or just benefit do you get from that? Not much but if you work
out say for 50 minutes only one time does it make it better? Not really. If you
work out for 10 minutes but you work out every single day for a whole year how
much are you going to accomplish? Oh yeah a lot right. Now if you up that to 15
minutes every day that is even bigger. Same thing with the water drinking. If you
want to drink four liters of water a day if you start with two sips and you keep
going all day you'll eventually end up at four liters per day and if you drink
four liters of water in a day you're gonna be so much more hydrated. If you're
more hydrated then all of a sudden your body's gonna function better. You're
gonna have more energy. If you have more energy you're gonna be able to get more
things done. If you can get more things done you're less stressed. Often two
tablespoons of water. That's where it begins. So celebrations are so important
when you accomplish something that you set out to do whether it's small or
huge you need to celebrate it in your mind. So get your pens out. I've given
you lots of time. First off you're gonna write down three things that you've done
ever in your life that you're proud of. So this can be huge things like the
birth of your children. It could be getting the horse, buying it, taking the
leap. It could be riding the certain horse that you have never done. It could
be going to your first horse show. It could be getting married to your spouse.
It could be something with your family or your your brothers and sisters. It
could be any one of those things. It could be jumping off a cliff in
Hawaii. Whatever it is I want you to write down at least three things that
you've done ever that you're super proud of.
Okay so now that you've got those three things I want you to write next to them
how it made you feel. Okay so if you wrote down that you jumped off a cliff
and it made you feel excited. It made you feel scared. It made you feel brave in
the end. I want you to write that down. So for each and every one of these I want
you to write down how it made you feel. Then I want you to circle how it made
you feel and that might be like a certain group of feelings and I want you
to really look at them and feel that again. That is celebrating those
accomplishments. You're gonna talk about yourself. So now you're gonna take those
things and you're gonna talk about them to yourself right now. So we're going to
use the the analogy of jumping off the cliff and this is making you feel brave.
And so you would say to yourself, wow I'm so brave. I'm so brave. I jumped off a
cliff in Hawaii and I'm so brave. Can you believe how brave I am? Can you believe?
Is anyone watching? This is how brave I am. That's that's a celebration that you
do with yourself and do it out loud. I don't care who's around. You've got to
get doing it out loud. So use your example here. Next thing I want you to do
the exact same exercise with writing three things down that you've done this
year that you're really proud of and how it made you feel.
So this year it could be say, you know, you had to start working from home. A lot
of people had to do that. You had to change jobs. You got a new dog and there
was a lot going on. You got a new horse. You had to retrain your
horse. Maybe that's why you're in this course because it came off of an injury
or it's new to you or just, you know, it needed to freshen up. You did that and
you accomplished this course. Maybe this course is one of the things you're proud
of, okay? So you're gonna write that down. You're gonna write down how it made you
feel. Say if this course was your example of something you've done this year that
made you proud and say it made you feel accomplished. Like you are completing
things. You're not procrastinating anymore. You're actually doing the things
that are in front of you and they're producing results and I want you to talk
to yourself about this subject and I want you to say to yourself, I produce
results. Look at me. I produce results. I did this course. I did all the steps and
look at the results it produced. I did that and I'm more celebrating because I
did that and I can do it again. So now I want you to go even deeper and I want to
think you to think of three things that you've done today. Maybe you're watching
this in the morning. Maybe you want to use yesterday. Maybe you're watching this
in the evening and you're gonna use today. So I want you to write down three
things that you've done today and you have to write three things. Force
yourself to make something like, you know, really grab a celebration. If you've
had a bad day, it does not matter. Grab a celebration. Make it happen for yourself
today. So write down three things that you've done today. Say I kept up with the
dishes. It could be something really small. I went out in road and I did the
groundwork exercise because my horse was crazy and I didn't want to get on but I
did the exercise anyway and I did the groundwork exercise. That is a huge
celebration, especially if you're working towards, say, you know, breaking
through procrastination or breaking through to make sure that you're
working on bravery with your horse or connection with your horse. It could be
something more specific. Like I read into the connection with my horse that I
needed to have and I stayed there and I was patient in the exercise and I kept
going with it and that was important to me. Okay, I want you to write that down.
Write it how it made you feel and then I want you to work back with it. I want you
to tell yourself that you are already how it made you feel because you've
already accomplished it. What this does that's so important is it actually
brings you to a place where you're creating a belief around what you
already did and it propels you to do even more and even better in the future
and we need that for riding, right? If you trot really well you know you can
canter really well at the simplest level. If you've gone to a horse show over here
you're gonna go to the next one you're gonna do even better. You create a
belief system around what you've already accomplished. Focus on the things that
you did well and it will propel you to do things better. So I'm really excited
to talk about this with you guys. We have one more week and I'm super excited that
you guys could share with me this week and I hope you've gotten all these
things written down so that you can celebrate with yourself every single
day. As always, for the sake of the horse.